welcome everybody
um my name's jonathan ray and i'm the
drinks editor of the spectator
and it's a real treat for me to
introduce my old charm and a
old chum of the spectator to peter gago
head wine maker of penfolds in australia
um penfolds has been making wine since
1844
it riles me sometimes when we think of
australia as
new world it is pretty old world in fact
they've got the oldest continually
producing cabernet sauvignon vines in
the world
and as i say they've been making wine
since 1844
penfolds was founded by dr christopher
penfold and his wife mary
and they've been making exceptional
wines ever since and for those of you
who probably know the conunga hill
cabernet shiraz absolute perfect crowd
pleaser
10 quid in the supermarket we've all
drunk it i still drink it
it's a great textbook entry level wine
but if that's the only one of penfolds
you know i beg you to think again we
have some
amazing wines here today to show you and
these
four wines we're going to try or talk
about a part of peter gago's
must-have icon wines and they are
really quite exceptional some of you the
more flushed amongst you will know
penfolds because of grange
um so between grange which retails for
gosh i don't know 500 quid and conunder
hill at
10 quid there are some exceptional wines
and it's a real treat i have to say i'm
biased i've always loved penfolds wines
and so i'm thrilled and um peter
has been i think you're the only the
fourth
uh headwind maker at penfolds and peter
it's fair to say that
you're aussie through and through but in
fact you were born
and brought up in south shields so
you're not actually a geordie i don't
think you're a
am i writing saying you're a sand dancer
indeed indeed whitley bay south shields
a subset is the nice way of putting it
geordie yeah so uh peter um it's
great to have you here you kindly
invited me to moscow
a few years ago to for the launch of the
block 42
uh penfolds which really is one of the
great icons of the wine world
and i think i last saw you when you
kindly hosted a
a really memorable uh dinner for the
spectator for spectator readers at the
marabon hotel
where you showed some incredible wines
you're a great advocate not only for
penfolds of course
but you've always been very generous
about your colleagues and competitors in
australia and i'm thrilled you're here
to
to chat about penfolds chiefly but also
give us your views on australia
um i should point out that much to the
chagra of our french
colleagues we now drink more australian
wine than we do
french wine in the uk and now is the
time really to
get to know australia so peter you're
as i say you're a boy a south shields
boy a sand dancer which i didn't even
know that was a description i only knew
of the geordie description but you're a
sand dancer
and peter welcome thank you for having
us
i should point out that peter is 11 000
miles away i'm near brighton
um in england and peter is stuck at home
so he says in melbourne i'm slightly
curious as to what hides behind the
curtain peter you look like you're in a
hotel room
somewhere very dodgy um but anyway peter
is
11 000 miles away in melbourne he should
be at the winery in adelaide but because
of covert of course he's stuck at home
um but peter i'm gonna stop rabbiting
but i'd love to know how a georgie boy
or a sand dancer from england
ended up as headwind maker of
australia's most famous winery
well it was a long time ago you know
moving across with my parents to
australia
uh back in 1963 actually that's an
indication of how old i
am a a youngster educated in melbourne
and i'm back here in melbourne at the
moment
uh yeah marooned literally because of
covert
the south australian victoria border
reopens tonight at midnight and i'll be
on the road tomorrow back to adelaide
back to south australia
back to mcgill back to the barossa
valley so
yes a long time ago and a lot of changes
in between but it's been a great journey
and and becoming part of
i don't even say a brand a culture that
is penfolds
uh is just so good you know this is i'm
about to head into my 32nd year
at penfolds no two have been the same as
they say and i can honestly
state that nothing stands still here
even if i am marooned i'm in a different
season to you tomorrow we head into our
first day of summer
i believe you're heading into colder
weather
sadly exactly so yes it's pretty um
gray and foggy outside um the fog on the
tine and all that pizza
yeah remember that yeah could you just
tell us a bit about your journey how you
became
interested in wine i mean i'm i'm
teasing you about
your your background it doesn't seem a
very
obvious route to becoming a very
celebrated winemaker how did you get
into one in the first place
well you know i think we go to higher
school we go to university and quite
often
you know the question of parents what do
you want to do when you grow up and for
a long time i actually didn't know so i
just continued what i was doing
and ended up teaching for about eight
and a half years chemistry and
mathematics loved it
science coordinator accelerated through
the ranks which enabled me
to make a decision to go and do another
degree in enology
at roseworthy my wife though girl wasn't
aware at the time that rosewood he was
in a completely different state of
australia she thought it was down the
road somewhere
and uh yeah we ventured across and
uh it's a fantastic degree in applied
science there
part of the university of adelaide now
uh the oldest agricultural college of
australia
and the roseworthy course is known
throughout the world and it's produced
some
incredible winemakers across many many
many
well well over a century um so
yeah and started at penfolds um
did quite well started off as a
sparkling wine maker
in 1993 i moved into the red wine
department and it's pretty hard to leave
the
red wine department of headphones and i
guess you could sort of say i'm still
there but we dabble and fortified of
course white wines
and breads and nowadays we'll talk more
about it
a little later we're dabbling in a few
other countries as well
so yeah the you know the book is not yet
written there are many many chapters
still to be written
and um tell me peter how about the
heritage
as i said in my introduction penfold has
been making wine since 1844
you're only the fourth head wine maker
your most famous predecessor of course
was matt schubert
creator of grange you have the oldest
continually producing cabernet
vines in the world how important is
heritage given that we see australia as
as innovative as indeed penfolds is but
it seems a
fine line to tread between heritage and
innovation
oh absolutely and this is the daily sort
of tension between
honouring styles of the past and not
continuing to innovate which we've done
throughout every year across the last
176
so you know we have to future proof
nowadays we've got this little thing
called climate change
not really little happening so we need a
lot of flex in the way we look at things
and that's not even looking at what the
consumer sort of
fashionable things do and change or
whatever
i co-hosted it not so long back with the
great olivia krug
and he wouldn't tell me you know what
month in 1843
crook was founded i think and i suspect
ken folds is only a few months later
and we love that tension and you know
one of the great things now about the
world of wine is it truly
is a world of wine and these wines sit
alongside some of the great wines of the
world
uh but a little bit different in terms
of penfolds
your earlier point about comunder hill
being at entry level
then the bins and then we go even beyond
range to special bins
and this is very unusual you know a wine
house
making wines to style almost like the
champa noir the house style
of tsunami the house style of rwt or
grange
or our flagship yatana it's a very
different mindset
on what we can do with the incredible
viticultural
uh sort of yeah ability
that uh our teams have access to
you know it's just incredible vineyards
incredible soils
uh and generations of expertise
and i think the strong point has always
been the penfold wine making
team and in that i include their
culturalists and others
you know i'm here talking to you now of
an evening here in melbourne
the rest of the team are preparing for
their work in the barossa valley
or in the southeast of the state
tomorrow and this happens every day of
the working year
so you know we're all we all have our
roles within this thing called penfolds
how big is the team out of interest the
the winemaking team of viticultural team
yeah well pure wine makers there are 10
of us now
and we will bring on some extra help
during harvest
in viticulture we have not only our own
vineyard managers
but we have we call them glas grower
liaison officers you see
we have very very good multi-generate
multi-generational relationships with
growers so
that has to be managed so logistically
across
our harvest which spreads across such a
huge area
we need all of these positions all of
these
interplays happening and that's what
enables us to make the range of wines
that we do
it's quite complicated it's not just one
style it's not just one viticultural
area
it's very very complex but the
complexity has evolved
over 176 years
you talk about multi areas or
multi-regional i guess this is
the most important philosophy behind
penfolds certainly behind grange and a
number of the other wines
is of course they're not just blends of
grapes and different parcels within
vineyards but they're
blended from multi-regions it's a
multi-regional blend
i can't think of a wine off the top of
my head as fine as
grange or some of the other ones in your
portfolio
that depends on this because coming from
a european standpoint we're all told
about told about terroir
and i'm sure when you sat and chatted to
olivier krug
he was banging on very proudly about the
terroir of krug
and that's why krug is what it is peter
i'd love you to
explain the philosophy of blending from
multi-regions
and also ask you could you ever conceive
of being able to make
a wine such as grange or rwt
or whatever in europe given that it is
blending i guess it's like saying i'm
going to make a great wine
with some syrup from the rhone some
cabernet from bordeaux
a little bit of carrino from uh the
longer dock and just a whisper of
pinot from burgundy oh goodness mate
i think you're predicting the future a
little bit here you've got the
look it it is really interesting but to
create some context here
at penfolds and you mentioned the term
term we are huge respecters of that term
and that sensitivity sensibility sense
of place
tewa is everything you know the site the
soil
the micro climate we do honor that
because we make three styles of wine
we still make single vineyard wines and
there are many of them now more than
there ever has been it's not just the
mcgill estate shiraz of our monopole
mcgill vineyard 15 minutes out of the
city center
you made reference earlier to the
kalimna block 42
10 acres of the world's oldest
continuously producing cabinet vines
we don't make a single vineyard every
year but occasionally we do
one of them is in the ampule that's one
start of one we make
the other two though we do make stars
for example um
our rwt can only ever come from
the barossa valley ab in one two eight
characters can only ever come
from the single region of kunawara you
know
they honor one viticultural area but
multiple vignettes within the one area
but the third style of wine that you
refer to which quite often is our most
successful
is the synergistic way of
blending across region and quite often
across style
we'll talk about in 389 in a moment when
we taste it but
they are truly using again and borrowing
the term
house style bin 389 will be the same
every year in terms of style but no two
are the same
climatically they're all different but
it is a cabernet shiraz blend
it is always cabinet predominant it is
always stored in quercus alba american
oak
and usually between 30 and 40
new to create that style but the
ingredients
come from just where we can best get
them in a given year
you know in south australia and not only
south australia we're noticing it now in
bordeaux in california and elsewhere
there is huge oscillation in ripening
in the compression quite often of
ripening
in adverse conditions happening and not
only fire
not only drought not only you name it
anything that can happen does happen
it's a thing called agriculture so
we have a means of you know sort of
flattening a little bit the huge
oscillations
by this multi-regional blending so for
us and it sounds a bit clear but
some of the parts blending should be
synergistic
as long as we abide the house style and
that's really what penfolds is all about
you know the junior wine makers serve an
apprenticeship learning what
these house styles are it's not about a
formula
it's about making wine to suit that
style to honor what has happened before
yet at the same time to try and make a
better wine
than what was made in one of the great
villages but not ego driven not i i know
better i know a new type of oak or a new
unit
it's not about that it's about all the
refinements
all the one percenters of just getting
these
magical blends to outperform some of the
better
releases that's really what it's about
so three styles of wine
the multi-regional blends perhaps our
two flagships yatana our chardonnay
and grange our red flagship are
multi-regional vends
but we can never go past the single
vineyard releases nor the single
viticultural
they all have their role in this thing
we call the penfold portfolio
well that makes sense and also the
proof's in the pudding isn't it i mean
the wines
are amazing um yes can i
can i mention as i said earlier i adore
penfold's wines you know i'm
a complete slave to your wines peter but
i do have a quibble and i've mentioned
this to you before
and it is you're numbering your wines by
the bin number
i find this very confusing and i
remember
years ago um taking and i think of
course i forget which bit number it was
but i took one of the bins been uh
2 or 12 or something i don't know what
it was to suffer
and it was something like 40 quid a
bottle i took it to dinner with a friend
of mine thinking he'd be thrilled
and he looked at it and although he
knows penfold's wine is great i think he
took it for
whatever the cheapest spin number was
and just put it away and open something
else
and what i wanted to say was actually
this bin is seriously fine
and some of the bin numbers are quite
low in price some of the bin numbers are
quite high and i get confused as to
whether it's been 389 or been 42 or been
407 or
been 169 or been 707
how how does the punter
know what he or she is getting
when you see one of these bin numbers on
the shelf
yeah look it's it's it's a great
question and one we're confronted about
all the time the confusion we say look
we come from australia that's what we're
out to do to confuse
you know but no look in all seriousness
in numbers
in a penfold context had an historic
derivation
uh i would ordinarily we were meant to
be doing this transmission
out of the mcgill winery but it's
terrific there i could almost take a
camera around with me and go
underground and show you what we're once
underground bins compartments vaults
call you what you will where we used to
store wines
in the days before refrigeration in the
days before air conditioning
for reasons different to the champions
you know a very hot place then
as hot as it is now with bottled wine
but we wouldn't sell it the next day
we'd store wines and we'd let them
mature in bottle
but they had to be temperature
controlled so the different vaults or
compartments
we call them bins had different numbers
that's sort of where it came from
now it's almost random they say bin 707
for example our flagship cabinet
actually did come from an ex-going
executive who happened to have a short
period of tenure
at uh at penfolds 707 pick a number any
number
but no 389 or 28 will be the same style
every year and i often choke with people
like for example this is a bin 28
because we're tasting it
but i can say if this were a bottle of
bin one two eight
you could get some white out and get rid
of the one two eight
on the label and the bottle would still
say penfolds
kunawara shiraz 2000
whatever so it's a shortcut
you know we're lazy in australia i often
say look what 128 everyone knows what
you're talking about
yeah kunawara shiraz from this vintage
whatever we don't say that
one two eight please but over time this
little secret code this little
knowledge bank people love it and in
fact a number of years ago we were going
to discontinue the use of for new wines
of bins
now i forget which one we release but we
called it something or other and there
was outrage
we want a bin and you know even our bin
138 which is the barossa it used to be
called barossa valley old vines grenache
mataro and people didn't like that now
it's called bin 138
so that changed in the 92 well
the first finish was 92 it changed about
10 years later
so yeah look you don't if you do damn if
you don't but we have many wines like
grange
etanus and henry and others that have
real names not bins but even if you look
at a label of
grange look closely it will say in 95
in small print yatana our flagship
an indigenous word an aboriginal word
meaning little by little or gradually
depicting the process by which we
created the first yutana
the 95 minutes released in 98. you look
closely at the label of yatana it says
bin 144
now symbolically there there were 144
trials
before the release of the first but look
it is a bit geeky it's a little bit
whatever
but in many instances you know in
america
especially australia three eight nine
you just go into a store
you know your your merchants say poplar
389 everyone knows what you're talking
about
you know this year we're celebrating
this one's 60th anniversary
generations have been brought up on this
now not only in australia in in the
united kingdom
most people know have been three eight
nine know that it's cabinetry as planned
and it's a bit of a shortcut but take
off 389 and the labor will still
pen phones cabinet shiraz 2017.
it's a shortcut yeah but then you could
you further confuse us
why i think um isn't there a bin 60a
that was i think i'm right in saying the
only
non-french or non-european wine
in the to canter magazines ten wines to
drink before you die
so what happened to sixty
good point yeah that was in august of uh
2004 that result yeah in the top 10
there were 100 wines the top 10 were
listed chronologically
in order the remaining 90 by country
alphabetically
and to your point the 1962 bin 68 came
in
y number seven of all wines
you know 37 judges from around the world
compiled that list it wasn't some fellow
in a back room with his mate
you know having a bit of a sniff in the
taste this is a really
serious thing but your question uh we've
released two of those across the years
but the second one wasn't called 6db
there was a 1962 pin 60a and there was a
2004 released
only two ever and that's what we truly
mean by special bins
one or two only ever made recent
examples like that include the bin 620
there was one made in 1966 and we
launched a second one out of shanghai
the 2008 rainy of the two maid uh been
seven from 1967 there's only ever been
one made
so they truly are wines positioned above
grange
intermittent one-offs that collectors
cue
up for uh the 68 though that you
mentioned the 1962 johnny there were
only ever 425 cases made
it was never commercially released uh
james halliday who you'd know well you
know the
one writer of australia for many years
said
you know quite possibly the greatest
australian red white
red wine made in the 20th century and i
said many times james words come tribly
why don't you write that anyway
not only did he write that but he went
on to write at a later stage
quite possibly the greatest australian
wine ever made
the 1962 vin 60a but yes a bim
in 68 and it was just
to um reiterate it was the only
um non-french wine in the top ten was is
that right or it was
in the top ten yes yeah the only french
non-french yeah
yeah with incredulous wines you know
1900 marco 45 you know
first grades that sort of thing uh drc
that sort of company
uh in the top ten yeah coming in at
number seven
yeah well that's one heck of an accolade
but listen you're making me thirsty now
so
should we try i think we're going to try
the bin 28. in 28 yeah
yeah well look this is i guess a wine
that can reinforce
what we were talking about earlier of
the meaning of bin
bin 28 was first made in 1959
and it's been released without
interruption
every year since every year since
it's always a warmer climate shiraz in
the early days it came
predominantly it will exclusively for
the first view from
our vineyard in the barossa valley
nowadays it's a blend from
warmer regions usually of south
australia
it's consecutively released to style
that style
never ever incorporates any newer so
bin 28 is sarah we call it shiraz
you know with unadulterated older oak
you can see here
this particular vintage predominantly
from the brosser valley
with a little bit of mclaren valve fruit
and something down in the southeast from
pathway
12 months in seasoned or older american
oak
the term hogs heads that's a 300 liter
barrel
different too of course a very 225
litres
so this style will be of this style
every year the bin 28 style has never
changed since 1959
but again reiterating what i mentioned
earlier no two of the same
people will collect bin 28 not only to
drink tomorrow or at christmas or next
year
great big 28s from terrific years like
good vintages have been 389 will last
for
many many years in fact currently the 71
the 76
the 1990 are drinking incredibly well
and i should point out and i know that
some of your subscribers
will soon hear a bit about the eighth
edition
of the rewards of patience book which
goes through every addition
every vintage not only of bin 28 but all
of our wines and gives
an updated drinking window this edition
8 is
literally just been released as we speak
and we hope to have copies in the united
kingdom
a little into the new year so only weeks
from now people will be able to access
this we call it
the form guide to all things penfolds
and you can look up and see what your
older bin 28s are drinking like at this
point of time
now whilst it might look like a little
bit of a propaganda piece it's not
an independent panel of judges from
around the world
put this book together use the term
before warts at all
you know in this book of the good the
bad and the ugly of all vintages
and with honest drinking windows and
assessments and bin 28
features right back to the ninth well
the early 60s 1959 so
drink it now it has accessibility in
youth
in a good year hold on to it for a bit
longer that
magic word choice you can do it now
later or hold on to a bit and look not
excessively expensive it's not
inexpensive but it's not
cost prohibitive we can buy a six pack
and this isn't a sales pitch
and go on the journey with the wine and
see whether we're right wrong or
whatever
you know many people johnny will prefer
the exuberance of the primary fruit the
opacity of youth
and we'll drink it within a year or two
others will want
secondary or tertiary characters and
might drink this as a 20 or 30 year old
the choice is theirs
not everyone has a seller more and more
people though are accessing wine storage
and or with wine cabinets used to know
but isn't it wonderful to have that
choice
and also i'm right in saying that of
this
collection of wines that you've curated
for spectator readers
they're four bottles and then this is
the free
fifth one so this is the wine that's
added
to the box gratis which is very generous
of you peter
um i don't have colleagues in our
twitter office
[Laughter]
well here's some of the twickenham
offers um how many parcels would have
been blended for this how many
talk me through the blending process
because i know it's just the one great
but talk to me
yes yes that still means that it is
yeah absolutely this is a very big blend
and a much larger blend than for example
grange by volume but the process is
quite similar
after harvest for example in this year
our harvest is six months
earlier than the northern hemisphere
harvest so we'll finish fermenting
usually late april may
end of may sometimes as late as the
start of june we will have what we call
classification tastings where every
parcel whether it be an oak
already or in storage and stainless
steel
is assessed we start with grange and we
work our way through the portfolio
so bin 28 might actually benefit by
getting a little bit of relegated
synonym fruit
you know bin 389 for example we refer to
that as baby grange because quite often
a bit of grange that didn't quite make
the grade for grange
cascades into 389 so we start at the top
and work our way through
so to your question in this bin 28 blend
of 2017
look i haven't looked it up but there
could well be over a hundred components
to create the house style of bin 28
in that year of 2017 and i can say this
now because we're released in august of
this year in australia the 2018.
they're so different but blind they're
unmistakably both been 28
but side by side very different ones are
17
one's from 2018. you know not unlike
any wine made anywhere you know whether
it be burgundy
bordeaux these wines also show that
vintage divinity variation
but by blending in the way we do as i
say we don't have the huge oscillations
and we can flatten those troughs a
little bit because again i mentioned the
word
agriculture earlier you know wind rain
right time wrong time you know we've got
to get around that
and that's what we do with blending yeah
because we're often told over in the uk
that there are very few
um vintage variations in australia but
that's
not true is it not true at all if i need
that with a case look
in the state of south australia we're
very lucky though we have a winter
dominant rainfall
we are the driest state of the world's
driest continent
you know we have id conditions just
incredulously good for growing grapes
the
clean and grain approach you know very
little reason to spray but we do have
years like for example 1969
the 2011 vintage there was a lot of rain
at the wrong time
that's a long time between drinks 1969
there's a little
milkshake in 1974 2011 they're about the
only three vintages i can think of just
instantly
most are pretty good if anything you
know heat now is an issue
drought obviously fires and that sort of
thing but
that's why we have many many different
vineyards
across many viticultural regions you
know it really is mitigating risk
it is climate proofing future proofing
and in fact the itana our flagship white
wine
the first yatana was a blend of adelaide
hills
and walunga fruit from just down the
road near mclaren
you know quite close really but nowadays
yatana can come from not four vineyards
not four viticultural regions
but four different states of australia
you know the high country in new south
wales tumbarumba in the snowy mountains
southern victoria adelaide hills highly
elevated vineyards in the adelaide hills
and we've even gone down south to the
island state of tasmania
you can't go any further south yet than
tasmania
we have no vineyards in antarctica
but that is extraordinary so how far yet
how far are the furthest vineyards that
you would use for the atlanta
however if you were to look at snow oh
hundreds and hundreds if not a thousand
or two k i haven't actually you know got
the protractor or whatever on the map
but you know southern new south wales to
southern victoria
to tasmania is quite a distance and
that's going
you know north to south if you go east
to west as well all the way
back west the adelaide hills that's a
huge catchment area
but what we do with those wines that
that chardonnay fruit and some of it
goes into our bin 311
you know which is in the picks of this
selection
that material is literally on the cusp
just on the cusp of physiological
ripening like chardonnay
you go another few hundred meters up the
grapes don't physiologically ripen
or in the instance of latitude you go
any further south they don't
physiologically
and it's very high risk in a cooler year
you know you need other areas as a
backup
very risky wine making but that's what
gives us that tightness that linearity
that clarity on the palette with our
chardonnays
and many of these chardonnays now are
astounding people from the
you know northern hemisphere with their
purity of fruit their
lightness on the palate their tightness
their definition
you can only do that by getting that
fruit exactly as you want it
and it doesn't come from one vineyard
every year
the vineyard is all important but it's
lovely to have that choice of vineyards
to blend with
a wine has just done very well in a
certain united kingdom
united kingdom competition in fact just
in the last week or two
it's a penfold summer reserve adelaide
hills chardonnay
it's a single vineyard chardonnay of
penfolds
so you can do it from single vineyards
but not the same single vinyard
every year and for some of our larger
blends
we can't be doing that we need a little
bit more
surety so with the
with this chardonnay and drawn from so
many
from so far afield do you press the
grapes
where they are and then blend the juice
or do you truck
the the grapes to adelaide i mean you
can't truck it from tasmania it's yeah
there are other ways you'll have to
know okay so just talk us through this
the logistics
yeah the logistics for chardonnay are
very different to that for red yes
hold punch press because with our fine
chardonnays we never crush anyway
they're very gently pressed
they're chilled down so literally the
juice is transported
um the adelaide hills whole bunches come
in and we do it all in situ
in the barossa at our winery but
elsewhere
no all done in situ where it's all
happening and logistically it's quite
complicated
the barrel fermentation of course all
happens in the barossa
at our mcgill winery we dabble only in
red
wine but you know with reds quite often
we will crush in situ
and in effect this the trip is a bit of
a cold soak almost quite often though
it's not
cold you know so already you're leeching
out color and flavor and character out
of the skins which is what you want with
red wine
with wide snow you want very little
phenolic transfer
you know you don't want that oxidative
thing happening or you want to minimize
it
and barrel fermentation is of course
everything now with chardonnay
you know lease management and barik
whole bunch pressing
but it's the sourcing that is probably
the the critical number one
you need that raw ingredient from the
right soil from the right vineyard in
the right year to go into that blend
right we've got slightly off track that
was my fault talk about chardonnay but
um the bin 28
it is as you said it is 2017
but the tannins are so soft it's really
velvety it's extraordinarily um
approachable now indeed
you know uh no what we refer to as the
lagic acid-derived tannins out of the
new oak so the tannins are really coming
from a little bit of yeah
two three year old of course there's an
impartation of tannin
but not to the same extent uh the tannin
out of the seed and the skin we try and
minimize
by not keeping the shiraz grapes on
skins or dare i say on
seeds for too long after the primary
ferment at a grange level
707 cabinet level rwt those ones don't
even finish their fermentation
and they're taken off skins they're
taken off seed
so you get the lovely more desirable
phenolics
the less green the less harsh the less
astringent
so you get that accessibility but it's a
little bit misleading because it's so
accessible ah
drink it soon no the mindset is very
different
you can have immediacy quite often in
accessibility
and that longevity to follow
it's not you know back in the old days
the mindset if it's going to go the
distance it must be unyielding as a
younger wine
and conversely if it's successful and
young it's probably just going to fall
over 10 years later
not so you know a great line doesn't as
we know become a great one in year 23 or
year 31
they start off good they just unfurl and
manifest different characters over time
so if you have that magical word that
balance day one
it should stay with you the bh the
acidity and everything is in balance
all the way through that lovely lifetime
of the wine
ideally well i must say it's in perfect
shape now it's so rich so
soft velvety really quite profound and i
i mean
i would love to see it in a few years
i'm not sure i could keep my hands off
it though because that is so easy to
drink
now and um yeah it's abused it's really
rich and
but it has that lovely freshness and i
guess that's the the acidity that gives
it a real freshness to it
absolutely and just the way it leaps out
of the glass you know the characters
there
and this is the thing every year you
know we do our own tasty notes and they
go out in those brochures and
what do you mean it's got this and that
you know you can't make them all sound
interesting
or spicy or whatever but the characters
just vary so much year to year that
primary fruit is manifested in many ways
but
it's unmistakable 28. if we had a glass
of 128 next to it
if i were to generalize it say the one
two eight from kunawara would have more
florals
more pepper more spice this has more of
you know
the ripened satsuma plum a little bit of
hoisin a little bit of character
other than just the grape but it's all
about primary fruit just
unleashing and uh yeah it's quite
captivating as we say quite often we
sometimes don't want to sip a wine
because we think what i'm experiencing
on the nose probably can't be matched
i'll only be disappointed
on the palette and as we know the great
lines over deliver on the palette what
you're initially sensing on the nose
yeah yeah well talking of great wines
we're also in this
this peter geiger's must-have icons
we've got the santon re
uh the 2016 which i think is one of
those bottles behind me
um and this is known as the purest
expression of
australian shiraz i think it's a 98
pointer according to
i think it was james halliday gave it 98
points um
the thing is is it a poor man's grange
or a rich man's conundrum hill
look dare i say neither it is its own
thing you know and it's a funny thing
you know uh
son henry from a penfold perspective
goes back to the early 1950s
a contemporary winemaker at penfolds of
max schubert the creator of grange
resurrected this style this style here
johnny goes back to 1890
before it bore a penfold badge in the
1890s and early 1900s
it was just called tsunami claret from
the ordana winery that we bought in the
1940s
only a stone throw from the mcgill
winery so it has an incredible heritage
but what we've been hugely respectful of
as was john daven at the time of the
resurrection in the 1950s
is the way it was originally made and
up until only a few decades ago the poor
man's grange full of what you will know
synonyms there might have been like a
dollar price difference
sadly for lovers of grange the price
went like that
thankfully for lovers of tsunami such as
myself the price went like that
not quite as steep so uh no
there is a cult following for this wine
tsunami around the world
it's a wine that's never been advertised
it's a wine that's never been entered in
one choice it's the antithesis
of a show wine you know it's not pumped
up on new oak
or alcohol or extract or it's tsunami in
fact
as a younger one it's quite understated
you could almost miss it
but not 20 30 40 50 years later
you know we've recently brought back
some fantastic 1933
1911 and 1901 synonym
you know for our rewards of patience
tasting that i referred to earlier for
the edition
eight of the text we tasted this back to
1958
62 the 71 like there's very little
difference between 71 grains and 71
synonymous
depending upon the bottle tsunami could
be half a point ahead
or half a point behind and that's saying
something
because the 71 grand is a legendary
grange vintage
so what we tend to say to people with
tsunami is
don't necessarily buy it every year my
colleagues won't like me saying that
pick the great ones and buy a heap of it
and that's what my friends do
you know i've put 2016. this is just a
personal thing
alongside the 2010 the 1990
and the 1971 those four i think are the
four
best synonyms over half a century
16 is one of the four so that's 16
10 90 and 71. that's quite a bold
statement so
you know we drink the 16 at the moment
it's a nice wine
don't be fooled this wine is just at the
start of its journey
i remember when you kindly invited me to
moscow for the launch of the
block 42 i was traveling with the very
lovely john stimfig another
drinks journalist and we were at the
airport
and you'd very kindly given us all all
the guests one bottle of the santon reed
to
take home and we only had hand luggage
we were only in moscow for two nights we
only had hand luggage and i thought oh
my god i can't put it in hand luggage
it's got to go in the hole
so i had a small rucksack that i put in
the hole and prayed that the bottle
would be all right
john had completely forgotten it it had
taken it on as hand luggage and of
course the
the um uh security beeped
and the two security guards very stern
russian security guards came over and
said what is this you know you're not
allowed to take
liquids on a plane what on earth do you
think you're doing and john oh my gosh
i'm
so sorry i said what is this wine and
john said it's quite a special wine from
australia
and the first security guard said how
special and john went
well actually really special and the
second security guard i swear he was
licking his lips said
what very very special and gentlemen
sadly yes
and the security guards looked at each
other and then gave it back to john and
said
you don't want to leave that here then
take it with you sir
so there is surprisingly
um the other wine we've got in our in
our pack is the um
rwt um the red wine making trail
um trials sorry so
this is known as to all its devotees as
rwt
how did it become a trial and how how
did it become a successful trial
can you just tell us a bit about its
background
yes look this was created in the era
of my predecessor john g val who
followed don dieter who followed max
shubert
and the penfile red wine making team at
the time we all knew we wanted to do
something a little bit different to
grange
uh almost as a counterpoint you know
grange
to a lot of people and you you sort of
touched in a little r but it's
a blend you know it's almost as if old
blends treating
you know oh it's uh in america note
quercus alba will
you know american oak at the moment is
not that fashionable we have
great american oak by the way which we
air dry in australia and creating the
barrels in australia we love american
oak
as we do franchot but to maintain style
differences
so we thought well hang on grange
multi-regional american aid matured why
don't we give people
a contemporary style mature this great
shiraz
in french oh and take it only from one
region
in this instance with rwt the barossa
valley
so grange multi-regional american rwt
frenchie matured single region and
the first vintage was released in the
year 2000 it was the 97
and ever since then it's a little bit
like synonymous people are slowly
finding out about it we make less rwt
than we do grange a lot of people aren't
aware of that
and we think yes smart money if i can
refer to it as that
has its eye every year nowadays on
synonym and rwt it grange is great you
know it's always going to be up there
and
we're very respectful of what it is and
special bins
you know the one ops but we now have
three great very disparate styles of
sarah
sinhanrei the most old-fashioned as you
put it provocatively
different style of charades still made
in australia
rwt very definitively regional
friendship matured very very
contemporary
and then the grain style that's sort of
at the top level obviously we make other
syrah wines as well
but yes it's really really taken off
without
really much well again promotion or
advertising or whatever the proof's in
the pudding
people over a period of time as i say
not long
the first was 97 which from the penfold
perspective is
four days ago uh you know they now know
about the swine
so we're very proud to include that in
the my spies
of that set brilliant and then
the next one is the bin 389
which we're going to try now and this is
also in this
must-have collection and this is often
known as the baby grange
and it is a 97 or a 98
pointer and i know we shouldn't really
dwell on price but
given this retails for i think roughly
60 pounds maybe a bottle
and i think grange could be around 500
does this
make it a real bargain i know 60 quid's
a lot
to spend on a bottle of wine but given
that it's known as baby grange and
grange is
so stratospherically expensive is this
something of a steal
look personally yes but you always have
to watch what i say about
being throughout night anything i say
here i need harvard and then divide by
10 afterwards
and you'll get close to what i really
sort of you know it is
it is a favorite always has been we've
grown up with the swine
i don't like using the word over deliver
bin 389 always has
and the term baby grains yes it does get
some cascading fruit
out of grange it does get grange barrels
from the year prior
for the use of the 101 year old oak in
this wine
but um in this instance it does have
new hope as well it's usually between 30
and 40 percent
but a lot of people collect bin
throughout nine and in fact
officially it's now the most salad
red wine in australia and i'll describe
what i mean by that
with all the records with wine art and
all the celery facilities
for a long time it was grange but
remembering we made well over 10 times
the volume of this to grant we should
have more
of this salad by virtue of the volume of
both
but that's an incredulous figure number
one solid red wine in australia
penfold's been 389 followed by grain
which is incredulous so it's not just
saying these are wines that are people
were buying today drinking tomorrow a
lot of people do by the way you can do
it with three eight nine
but a lot of people are now drinking
their wines
of this wine from the 70s and the 80s
you know in a compounding sense
you know they buy them every year and
then they drink them as 10 year olds so
they drink them as 20 year olds
and you can very very safely do that
with this so
that propensity to age that longevity is
linked to grange
this shiraz component not the cabernet a
little bit of relegated cabinet
707 will go into the swine so
it really has for many decades and we're
now celebrating
in 2020 the 60th anniversary
of this style so it does have the track
record it does have the runs on the
board
this is not fancy word smithing or you
know nice back label or whatever
it's quite understated bin 389 cabinet
shiraz
a wine we're very very proud of and this
vintage is the
seventeen i think seventeen yep yep
so what yes this particular year
well you know i i look at some of my
notes which i've scribbled down in front
of me
i can't go to that and say well the 18
for example has something of the order
of 38 percent new
this has 29 percent ua this particular
release has
54 cabinet if i'm not wrong a 58 i know
54 percent
i'm sure that will come up on the screen
yeah 54 cabinet 46
shiraz but if we look at the vineyard
regions on the screen there we can see
it is very much an exemplar
of multi-regional blending you know
macharonville the barossa valley
pathway rattan bully down in the
southeast
so we've got warmer climate fruit from
the clan valley nebrasa
coupled with dovetailed into cooler
climate
fruit from down south and pathway and
rattan bully
to create as mentioned the house style
of bin 389
a style that's never wondered you know
always stored in quercus alba
american oak never sees any french oak
for this particular star
if you look at its stable map in 407
cabinet
it gets to share french oak in american
oak
there are other ones that are
exclusively french oak there are other
ones like this exclusively american
but in this instance as is the case
we're looking at you can see on the
screen 29
new 50 1 year old and 21
2 year old hogsheads all workers out
there
american owned that's extraordinary i
mean you can really
notice the cabernet influence there
there is that hint of
cassie's it's got more of a tannic
backbone than the um
28. but again incredibly approachable
that's
you know you could drink that absolutely
yeah you know it's the second or the
third set where you realize that you've
got another
level on bin 28 which i don't mind
saying i'm not pushing bin 28
down by elevating you know the merit of
389
28 is what it is it's 389 is a more
expensive wine and it should
be it's got higher quality fruit in it
it's got new oak it's very very tailored
you know this is if we're in bordeaux
we'd be blending cabernet
with merlot or cabernet franc or petit
pedo
that the great australian red wine blend
is a cabernet
with syrah shiraz or shiraz with
cabernet it just works incredulously
well
and they age so well now the 1990 i had
to do the arithmetic i was talking to
someone the other day you know the 1990s
doing that at the moment
and i think to myself it's a young mind
then you did the arithmetic
30 years old how did that happen johnny
how can a 1990 be 30 years old
oh what happened
but this has such a lovely savory note
on the finish doesn't it
there's all the succulent fruit the
softness there are the town insert but
there's that lovely
savory finish that just brings it all
together
that's a fabulous one very different
texture the oak is
acting there it's not sort of taking
over it's you know
framing the wine but to your point the
savory that lovely texture that goes
all the way to the finish and
it's not trying to be something that
isn't it's not pumped up again on
alcohol or extract or whatever there's
just a nice balance to it
i think the best of it's ahead of it to
be honest but to your earlier point you
know
accessible already well it's just i mean
i
tend to leave my wines too long but then
when i try something like this i think
why wouldn't you drink it now i mean it
is just so lovely but
i remember my old boss my old boss at
berry brothers
uh simon berry is such a lovely guy and
i was once talking to him about
how long one should leave wines and he
said no you try
one and it may be a bit young but you
get all the the joy of thinking how it's
going to turn out and then you try one
more month or six months later and he
said that is why the good lord put 12
bottles in a case
because when you get to the last place
should be perfect
absolutely and we spend a lifetime don't
we you know perfecting the craft of
drinks sooner or later or how compressed
to have the 12 or how allocated that
journey should be and that's part of the
enjoyment of wine
making the odd mistake and you know the
worst case scenario is when you buy some
of these wines oh
you have to drink them a bit earlier
than you anticipated you know but it is
a mortal sin holding on to them for too
long
are we caulking clinics around the world
we're now into the 29th year
of those three caulking clinics and
invariably it's not just about putting
new corks into old bottles and vintages
it's literally
you know pleading with some people to
like please drink it
you know we've put a new cork in it's no
longer leaking we've corrected the you
know the head space the alec or whatever
but this wine is ready you know and
they're very educational a lot of people
just think the older they get the better
they get well you know it's a parabola
isn't it it's sort of
up to a point the great ones will
flatter some of the great ones for
decades but they
all ultimately go into a decline phase
and everyone seems to want to drink the
wine at the end of the plateau
or in that decline phase and i'm
thinking no no no
you know please on the ascent or the
start of the plateau
if you really know the wine you know
edge it out a bit further but
not in decline please but again that's
all part of
wine and learning about wine and
experiencing it and
going on that journey you don't want to
be like the gardener who says
oh peter it's so nice to see you i wish
you'd come last week because those
daffodils were out and they looked so
beautiful but they're gone now
or i wish you could come next week when
the roses are out you know you just want
to
get it right yeah yeah exactly
you mentioned the re-caulking clinic can
you just explain a bit about that
because that is something that penfolds
is very well known for
the people can take bottles and have it
recalled and assessed by an expert
can you just explain how it works
absolutely well the great thing about
this process too
is to this day they are still free a
free
service to pinfall collectors any red
wine of ours that is 15 years or
older can be taken to a clinic a lot of
people in the early days just thought it
was for grange and some of the flagships
no any penfold red wine 15 years or
older
when the client comes in we assess the
level we visually inspect the bottle
we have a little template if the wine is
too far down
we say straight away well sorry we can
recall this for you but we can't certify
it
and we certify in conjunction either
with christie's or sotheby's or in
australia with lankans
so we only try 15 mil or less of the
wine which is 2
or less of the volume of the wine if we
took out any
more than that then we're really
affecting the integrity of what's left
we're putting too much into the bottle
it's a blend of two vintages then almost
and that's the reason too why we will
only ever recall
once because we can't organoleptically
assess
a two percent addition we've tried that
after a clinic a year after a clinic 10
years after a clinic compared with an
unadulterated wine at a museum but if
you did it a second time would be
percent and you can detect that
difference quite easily
but yes uh the new cork goes in stamped
and dated
a new capsule tissue wrap certified if
the wine is successful
but what we also do if a wine is not as
it should be
that given vintage it still might be
drinkable but not
certifiable it will get a white dot it
won't be certified
it will get a plain cork and no capsule
so nothing's been lost
it's just that you know in effect our
ulterior motive is to take bad lines out
of the system
in effect improving the gene pool but
it's great you know around the world
these have been happening now as i say
for 29 years we've done right across
china across asia across europe
i think we've done four possibly five in
london but you know a number in hong
kong
australia we do it every two years every
capital city you realize after 29 years
in australia
eight penfold winemakers working for
three days from nine in the morning till
six at night
it's just incredulous we thought after
10 20 years
you know the response would diminish the
other way
and it's great for the world of wine too
the the actual
emotion and the you know just the
experience is very camera friendly you
know tv stations come in
sometimes radio interviews lots of you
know it really helps
make this thing called wine a little bit
more
meaningful you know because these these
are just models of wine as we've often
said they're stories
everyone who comes into the clinic
whether of a multi-millionaire or mum or
dad off the street doesn't much matter
where they bought it how much they paid
for it was it a gift is it a family
heirloom you get all of that sort of
thing happening
they're great you can tell i don't like
going to them
and when you when you certify do you
certify that it's
the quality it should be or you're
certifying it to to last another
10 or 15 years it's certified to a
benchmark of what that vintage should
be like at that point of time like as an
example a 1968 grange i've never been
much cared for
it opens up almost with a naphthalene
nose it blows off but i've never much
cared for that so
i don't look at a 68 range and score it
as if i'm looking at a 2010 or a 90 or a
great 53
if it is as it should be for the 68 to
get certified
but you know you're not improving the
worth of that bottle
and i say to people you're not giving it
another 50 years life
what you are doing is you're arresting
further deterioration
due to oxidation or leakage or whatever
and people are very good you know the
session because you're dealing directly
with a wine maker is almost like a free
counseling session
we call them clinics red wine recalling
clinics because it's very clinical
you know the white gloves almost
everything's white
everything is very pristine you know no
nonsense the owner gets to taste his or
her wine
they usually agree there have been a few
tears here than there over the years
but you know nothing too dramatic but
everyone is treated the same we have
certified many bottles but we've also
rejected many bottles
and there's been very little disputing
you know people usually know
and they can tell even before you open
them what to expect
but some people are hugely elated after
the experience others are disappointed
but
everyone leaves reasonably happy and for
us
what would you rather spend money on you
know big billboards or whatever
no recording clinics are a great i think
end use of
you know a few of our dollars because
they are very expensive programs to put
on around the world
yeah yeah um thank you and
um leaving the red wines and the
re-caulking for a minute um
i'd love to talk to you about your
champagne uh project
because you've recently gone into this
um um
cahoots with champagne tiano to make a
pen folds tiano champagne i'd love to
know a bit more about that
how it came about and whether there are
any other projects
like that i'm a huge fan of your father
grand
tourney port and it is father grand
touring not grandfather torn isn't it
father graham's well we have a father
would you believe
a grandfather and a great grandfather
there are three different levels three
different ages support and then there's
the ultimate the 50 year old
liqueur tourneys not ladies word port
anymore but everyone knows they are a
tourney
exemplar but no look the champagne
project is hugely exciting
we used to of course and it was great
when we released the three champagnes
out of the 2012 champagne vintage it was
wonderful to see alongside that
a 1912 pen folds mitchenbree
which we in those days called champagne
but of course it wasn't in california in
australia we used the champagne it was
wrong to have used it but
it was modeled on you know the great
benchmark of this thing called champagne
so it was wonderful the century in
between them the 1912 mitchell bria
penfolds and the 2012
tno by penfolds chardonnay pinot noir
cuvee
uh the other two wines is a blanca blanc
single vineyard grand cru from avis
and a 2012 single vineyard grand cru
long to noir from ie so
very much done in the penfold way
starting at the top
there were those three ones because they
are not inexpensive australian dollars
280
a bottle now in the new year there will
be
a non-vintage rose coming out not a 280
but at 80
and we're very very excited by that
because you know we want
people to try and drink these champagnes
but the question of well why champagne
well
why not you know we love australian
sparkling wine i used to make australian
sparkling wine i joined penfolds in the
late 80s to do exactly that
for my first four years at penfolds i
was in sparkling wine
but we discontinued and now we've
resurrected it with
champagne the tiano family are a
wonderful worldly family they have an
involvement in two other champagne
houses as well as some bordeaux
properties stanislaus who i work with
directly and the two chapter cards
nicola and laurent uh and stanislas but
stagnant's father alain
was a champagne broker many years ago so
you know ultimately we hope we will be
able to buy some vignants of our own but
not just for the sake of buying it
that's why we're in no hurry to buy
anything but this collaborative thing
is just so good and it it
i often say when things are real they
happen and this has been such a natural
easy thing that has already gained
you know great thought at sports so
we're extremely happy with the way it's
gone
and with the three wines out of 2012
very very pleased
and is it an equal partnership between
the two of you how does it work i mean
you give the wine making expertise
they bring the fruit oh no no no
uh i am part of their team you know they
have
the champagne wow the local knowledge
both
in the vignons and in the winery i bring
uh sparkling wine sort of know how to a
certain extent
there's a member of the blending team
you know
with them it is very much uh
you know a coalition of of partners
really
um and in this instance the fruit is
accessed by them but this is a toe in
the water for us you know
um last year i was able to get and walk
the vineyards and you know
i i do the blending obviously the visage
trials this year we had to do virtually
but even last year when i did the size
trials we didn't even go into champagne
we did them at the tno office
in um houseman in paris you know
so uh we had everything it was just like
being back at our winery with penfold
wine makers everything was done blind
and we had just as many disagreements
uh you know and then we came up with
what we thought
was the best decision for those three
wines but the ones we've just done for
the 2000 the next vintage 2013 the two
single vineyard lines we did that just
about three weeks ago
and we want weren't quite as concordant
but that's what
teamwork is about that's what winemaking
teams are but
we're across oceans doing this
classification
but it was done virtually um and quite
successfully we hope that the proof will
be in the pudding
yeah yeah and as i said i'm a huge fan
of your tawny which i think is
is woefully underpriced i have to say
it's such good value
but given that you make such good port
styles
if you're doing other collaborations can
we expect to see a pen folds
port from the doru valley with the
simmingtons or the
taylor floodgate partnership oh well
well tell the flakey partnership you
know taylor flad gate and yateman about
it in 1692
david gimeron studied with us at
roseworthy you know when you go to
portugal whenever we can and david gets
back over here
but look the duro is the giro their
village ports
wow their 24th are very different to our
styles
but we have been making ports
those 20 stars since the you know early
1800s
the portuguese had to ship wine across
an english channel
back in the day and they fortified them
to make that journey down the giro
across the channel into london or
whatever
we had reverse oceans 12 000 miles to
get back to the mother country of
england
so back in the day you know pinfalls was
90 plus percent
fortified so our history you know our
blending our solara systems our house
blends
really do have a fortified derivation
so you know we we pride ourselves on the
fact that we're still making those wines
and when we're released the 50 year old
just a few years ago now
you know people had said you know these
wines are multiples of the price of
grain
oh you'll never sell them well there's a
few for them each year admittedly at the
50 year old level
there aren't there isn't much in the way
of volume but 50 year old great
grandfather grandfather father
in our club three lovely tears
of a wonderful expression that is quite
essentially australian
in character very different to the
portuguese tourney styles
peter you're a sand dancer geordie
whatever you will
you're now in australia you've got this
collaboration with
tiano if you weren't making wine in
australia so successfully
is there any way you would like just
personally like to be making wine
look uh one thing we haven't covered uh
with dabbling at the moment
in bordeaux we're also dabbling in
california steph darton and andrew
borden two pen pal winemakers
that will be revealed in march of next
year that is actually happening
but personally i'd like to go back to
the home of
dr christopher olsen penfold perhaps not
too far out of sussex
i don't think i'll go all the way back
up north to the northeast uh to make
anything but wouldn't it be good
dabbling in some of that limestone saw
down the south there
i'll say no more i will like
i wait to hear more with interest
because that's exactly where i'm sitting
at the moment
in the south dance but peter peter gago
as always it's such a pleasure to to see
you i wish we were
in the same room rather than 11 000
miles away but
you know i'm a huge admirer of yours i'm
a huge admirer of your wines
and thank you so much for giving us your
time today but also for curating this
really lovely
collection of wines so this is peter
gaigo's must-have
icon wines uh you can find details
either on the spectator
wine club website or winery collection
the winery collection
dot com and we've got four stunning
wines for 320 pounds
plus a free bottle of the bin 28 which
i've just tried and i can tell you is in
astounding form
and peter you as always are in
astounding form
you look younger and healthier whenever
i see you so
bless you peter if only thank you for
joining us
thank you for joining us and thank you
so much for putting together
this really nice collection of wines
peter see you again soon i hope you
appreciate it
goodbye everyone thank you for joining
thank you spectator
thank you
you